this video was brought to you by raycon
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
we've all seen and read reports of ponzi
scheme scandals getting exposed the
details always talk about a significant
number of people who have lost their
savings in these schemes
but even after investigations arrests
and sentences new scammers will pop up
and keep doing the same thing over and
over again
but what exactly is a ponzi scheme and
what are the signs to look out for and
how can you protect yourself and what
are the biggest ponzi schemes of all
time
you might be surprised to find out that
the us government might be running the
biggest ponzi scheme in history
according to some economists
so stay tuned until the end of the
episode to learn about that one
let's get into it
first of all what is a ponzi scheme
a ponzi scheme is an investment fraud
the scheme promises high and sometimes
quick returns but in reality it's just
paying off existing investors with funds
collected from new investors who have
also been fooled
fooled by the promise of a quick buck
ponzi schemes use money from their new
investors to pay off old investors while
taking a cut for themselves
since there is no money being earned by
selling a product or a service
ponzi schemes require a constant flow of
new money to sustain
not surprisingly after a time it becomes
increasingly harder to find new
investors and when that happens the
scheme fails
a ponzi scheme is not to be confused
with a pyramid scheme
a pyramid scheme requires recruitment to
bring in more people to increase their
returns a ponzi scheme may or may not
need that for example
a ponzi scheme would be something like
bitconnect a fake cryptocurrency that
promised huge returns from a mysterious
ai trading algorithm but in reality it
used money from old investors to pay off
new investors
and let me tell you that we are really
changing the world as we know it
the world is not anymore the way it used
to be
no no
be connected
wow
thousands of victims swindled out of
more than two billion dollars maybe
receiving some justice after one of the
leaders of a crypto scheme pleaded
guilty this is believed to be the
biggest cryptocurrency fraud ever
charged criminal he says this scam run
through a crypto lending program called
bit connect is believed to have swindled
thousands of people around the world out
of more than two billion dollars worth
of bitcoin they claimed that if you
traded your bitcoin for their currency
cryptocurrency called the bit connect
coin that a trading bot would make sure
that you didn't lose any money also
offering investors returns as high as 40
per month but prosecutors say bit
connect actually operated like a ponzi
scheme using investor funds to repay
other bit connect investors
a pyramid scheme on the other hand
relies heavily on recruiting so
something like metabolife where members
would sell supplements and take a cut of
the sales of those who they recruited
forming a pyramid
now have you ever wondered why an
unusual word like ponzi is associated
with financial fraud its name is as such
because it's named after a man named
charles ponzi
so who was charles ponzi
charles ponzi was a swindler known for
starting a scheme of this kind in 1920
in boston
charles ponzi was born in 1882 in italy
as a young boy he kept stealing from the
church so much that his family got sick
of him and deported him to america in
1903
charles worked in a restaurant as a
waiter but continually shortchanged the
customers keeping the difference so he
was fired
in 1907 he moved to canada and because
of his skills with numbers he got
employed at a bank
here he would forge the signatures of
clients and cash their checks he was
caught and spent three years in prison
after his release charles went back to
the us and started up a scheme to
smuggle italian immigrants from canada
to the us
again he was caught and jailed for two
years
this time when he got out he went to
boston and in november of 1919 he came
across the idea for his grand scheme
supposedly this was achieved by buying
discounted postal reply coupons in other
countries and redeeming them at face
value in the us where the currency was
much stronger
he promised clients a 50 profit within
45 days or 100 profit within 90 days
in 1907 an international postal congress
had agreed to issue postal reply coupons
throughout the world
the bearers could redeem these
international coupons for postage stamps
in their local country
this was to address a real problem
immigrants who came to america could
afford to buy stamps the relatives who
stayed home could not so this was a way
to allow relatives back home to write
back to the family in america if you
went to a european post office with
american dollars and bought post-reply
coupons and then brought them to this
country and cashed them in
you got us postage many times more
valuable than the us money you spent for
them and this was the premise ponzi
believed that for every dollar of postal
reply coupons purchased he could earn
five dollars when he redeemed them for
stamps
with a 400 percent profit from these
initial purchases ponzi would buy
additional coupons and redeem them for
even more money
it seemed to be a proposition that
couldn't lose
the only issue with this plan was that
ponzi would need to employ people to
line up and collect coupons and stamps
gather them up and ship them overseas so
this would probably cost more than the
money generated from the scheme itself
so
charles ponzi decided to buy no coupon
stamps at all and just tell people that
the scheme would make them rich double
your money in three months
america was booming in 1920 so people
were all looking for a quick way to get
rich
wild financial speculation was all the
rage so ponzi fit right in he was
charismatic and had a gift for talking
so everyone wanted a piece of the pie
and word quickly spread around
some people would take out their life
savings from a bank to invest with ponzi
but the thing was ponzi would actually
pay back investors as promised so the
whole thing seemed legitimate and people
went crazy
by march of 1920 investors had thrown in
four hundred thousand dollars but ponzi
owed them six hundred thousand because
of the promises of a scheme
most people trusted him so much that
they kept their money in so they could
earn even more
because of this charles could always
make the payments when they came due
two months later in may investors had
thrown in 1.6 million and by july this
had swelled to 41 million but at this
stage charles owed 55 million and that
was the problem
the more money charles ponzi received
the more in debt he was if he promised
to double everyone's money he would just
be owing more and more
all of this didn't matter though as long
as everyone didn't want their money out
at once
soon ponti was averaging 3.4 million
dollars a day
he bought himself a 7 million home with
a heated pool and air conditioning
absolutely unheard of in 1920
he bought the very same shipping firm
when he smuggled italian immigrants just
so he could fire his old boss
just six months ago he was broke but now
he could have anything he wanted
massive crowds were growing outside of
ponzi's office and officials got
suspicious
police were called in to investigate but
after they talked to charles ponzi two
of the three officers ended up investing
in fact a quarter of boston's police
force were investing with charles ponzi
on the 26th of july a boston newspaper
ran the first critical story of ponzi
it stated if ponzi could make 300 profit
for his investors why does he put his
money in the bank where it would only
make him two or three percent why not
just invest all the money with himself
it was a good point
and another article stated that the
numbers didn't add up there would have
to be 160 million of these coupons
circulating to amass such profits but in
reality there's only about 27 000 of
these in the world and there was also no
reports of massive purchases of coupons
when these news articles broke there was
a massive panic a riot ensued at ponzi's
office
27 million dollars were withdrawn in two
days but ponzi could afford to pay
everyone back and he did it with a smile
while serving people coffee and donuts
as they lined up
nerves were calmed and people actually
reinvested
but it wouldn't last
government regulators and more bad press
came ponzi's way the latter of which
stated he was completely bankrupt
it started another panic and a rush for
people to get all of their money out
over 200 million dollars had been
invested but ponzi was short 110 million
dollars everyone tried to get their
money out at once and he couldn't pay
by august of 1920 it was all over
ponzi was indicted on 86 counts of fraud
and many investors lost everything
it was a massive lesson for them and us
to never just follow the crowd and
always do your research before investing
even though charles ponzi got convicted
and jailed for his deceit it did not
deter others from coming up with such
schemes
so why do people keep falling for it
almost everyone wants to earn easy money
and get rich
in the real world this usually means
that you need to work hard for it but
it's a human tendency to look for
shortcuts but taking shortcuts often
leads to trouble as is with the case
with ponzi schemes
but it's not necessarily greed that
attracts people towards them
ponzi schemes are designed in such a way
that they appear legitimate
investors may genuinely see it as a
promising avenue for investment
later on in the episode we'll take a
look at some warning signs to watch out
for when deciding if an investment is a
ponzi scheme or not
the organizers of this kind of fraud
usually target those who have spare
money or those who need money
both are looking for quick and high
returns
usually the unemployed all those coming
from a financially weak background fall
prey to these schemes
essentially it all boils down to how
convincingly the ponzi organizer can
fabricate a story a story of quick and
assured success
playing on the ambitions dreams
financial situation and financial
literacy of people
emotions can often overthrow logic so
people end up believing that they're
being helped when they're actually being
conned
so let's take a look at five of the
biggest ponzi schemes in history
number one the 593 million dollar fraud
by a minister of scientology reed
slatkin
reed slatkin would start his scheme in
1986. he would get people including some
very high profile names and many other
scientologists to invest in what was an
unlicensed quote investment club
he would pay out large sums of money to
investors claiming that his investments
were working but again in reality he was
just doing that old method of using new
investor funds to pay off the old
investors he scanned around 800
investors for more than 593 million
dollars across 15 years before being
caught he admitted to fraud in 2002 and
was jailed for 14 years
number two the 1.2 billion dollar fraud
by scott rostein
scott rothstein started inviting
investors into his ponzi scheme he
claimed to purchase highly confidential
legal settlements using his law firm
rothstein's legal specialty is suing for
sexual harassment a down and dirty game
where defendants pay big money to settle
lawsuits quickly and quietly those are
usually paid out over a long period of
time rothstein used wealthy investors to
pay his clients up front promising the
investors a big return on their money
over time in some cases it was a promise
of more than 200 percent
i was shown with a confidential
settlement agreement looked like and
it had all the information was blacked
out it had the name of the plaintiff the
name of defendant was blacked out the
attorney was blacked out
everyone was backed out he wanted me to
invest in something that couldn't be
verified i didn't even know if it was
real in fact i didn't even think it was
real
the idea is a bonanza attracting big
money players like a modern day gold
rush we three kings be stealing the gold
scott ran with movie stars rock stars
kid rock pam anderson
athletes superstars dan marino alonso
morning sarah palin there was pictures
in his office of him shaking hands with
jeb bush and george bush from forging
documents with judges signatures to
making corrupt law enforcement officers
to do his bidding scott often went to
great lengths to sustain his fraud
people in the community were always
asking how are they growing so fast
where's that money come from and i would
always say i don't know but not from the
practice of law we were offered 207
return and i wanted to see how much
money you need to invest to get rich i
calculated if you keep in 150 000
for 13 years that 150 000 turns into 21
trillion dollars that's enough to pay
off the entire uh deficit of the united
states and have more money beside he
started off with hundreds of thousands
of dollars he had to return millions
then tens of millions and hundreds of
millions so it had a collapse there was
no way to go forward
he ran out of funds to pay investors by
early 2009 he raised an extra 100
million dollar investment but that still
wasn't enough to keep the scheme afloat
when he knew his time was up he fled to
morocco but soon returned to the us and
was arrested at that point tempers flare
it's a wrestling match of sorts outside
a florida courtroom this after scott
rothstein who has ties to rhode island
pleads guilty to a billion dollar ponzi
scheme
he pled guilty in court and was
sentenced to 50 years in jail in 2010
number three
the 3.7 billion fraud by tom petters
businessman thomas j pettis was
convicted of mail fraud wire fraud money
laundering and conspiracy for the
operation of a 3.7 billion ponzi scheme
thomas convinced investors that by
putting money into his organization they
would fund the purchase of retail
merchandise that would then be sold to
discount retailers for a profit
however no such investments were ever
made the funds were diverted for other
purposes such as paying off those who
helped organize the fraud and also
financing scott's extravagant lifestyle
this is how petters was able to manage
his scheme at pci first you need to ask
yourself how do stores such as walmart
costco best buy and other big box
retailers sell merchandise so cheaply
one answer is found in a little-known
industry known as diverting or supply
chain management in today's market many
retailers do not like to keep a large
inventory instead they buy products as
they have a need to sell
this concept is called just-in-time
retailing to keep their prices down they
reach out to a middleman petters was a
master diverter here is how his program
worked
first he brought on board investors to
finance the deals
their money was put in a locked box
account for safekeeping the money was
then funneled through a business called
nationwide where they would buy
merchandise from closeouts or stores
going out of business in bulk for low
prices
[Music]
eventually they were able to buy large
lots of inventory directly from the
manufacturer
next the merchandise was shipped to a
warehouse where it was held until a deal
could be made where it would be sold at
a higher price to a retailer
[Music]
the retailers would still save money by
not having to maintain such large
inventories
ultimately the money from the investment
would go back to nationwide where they
would take their cut and the investors
money would be put back into the lock
box where they would get their return on
their investment this was a very
lucrative deal for everyone involved
the problem was at some point peter
stopped buying merchandise the
warehouses were empty and nothing was
being sold
all the returns investors were making
were coming from the new investors with
pedders taking a cut off the top for
himself
the scam was reported to the authorities
by one of his co-conspirators in 2008
and he was arrested soon afterwards he
was convicted in december of 2009 and
was sentenced to 50 years in prison
number four the seven billion dollar
fraud by r alan stanford alan stanford
was among the wealthiest men in the u.s
he built a lavish lifestyle from banking
and smooth talk
but his slick sales pitch turned out to
be a lie
stanford ran one of the biggest ponzi
schemes in american history
that is until his house of cards
collapsed
r alan stanford the chairman of stanford
financial group orchestrated a 7 billion
fraud by selling certificates of
deposits via his company's offshore bank
in antigua
he cheated 30 000 investors from a few
dozen countries and pocketed some of the
proceeds
he used the money to gamble in business
ventures acquired dubious real estate
deals and even on cricket tournaments
he got a little bit friendly with the
players wives and girl friends uh we can
see some pictures of this the english
players not particularly pleased that's
matt pryor's wife sitting on his knee
and there was just a little bit of
disquiet amongst the england players
when they saw uh the behavior of set
alan stamford with their various wives
and girlfriends the daily mail has
picked up on this and has that very
picture with the england players fury at
stanford's antics with the wags turning
into an ego-fueled
saying that players were gobsmacked
uh is it fun being a billionaire
well um
yes
yes yes i have to say it is fun being a
billionaire i think it's hard work
there's hard work but as they say behind
every great fortune is a great crime
certificates of deposit were stanford's
bread and butter
they were like buying a savings bond and
customers thought they were insured
stanford became a catchphrase for safe
so what he did was he went out and sold
certificates of deposit to investors
they bought them he would pay them
interest
and he paid the interest from the new
investors
banks are supposed to take certificate
of deposit money and put it in safe
investments getting a small return which
they then use to pay their investors
providing investors with a solid return
on their investment stanford didn't do
that he used new investors money to pay
the interest to the old investors in
other words a classic ponzi scheme so a
classic
no real underlying investment that's
making money and what he did in the
meantime was take money out of the bank
and spend it on his lifestyle stanford
promised approximately three percent
higher returns than similar investments
sold by other banks
a profit that made alan stanford
certificates of deposit attractive to
investors
stanford said he could promise those
higher returns because his bank was run
smarter and more efficiently than other
banks
employees were not supposed to ask too
many questions about where the money was
invested people say how in the world has
this business of yours grown alan i say
well simply because we do things
differently many times we do them the
way they used to do them 20 years ago
but at least one employee charles haslet
did start asking questions
in fact every time i brought up anything
in meetings everybody was looking at
looked at me very shocked but do you
think people didn't ask questions
because the money kept flowing sure a
blind ignorance very very fancy i didn't
see any substance i interviewed i talked
to the brent to the manager of the bank
he didn't seem to know a lot about
banking in general
on being arrested stanford denied all 14
allegations
in march 2011 he was convicted on 13 of
14 counts and was sentenced to 11 years
in prison and a u.s judge called alan
stanford's operation one of the most
egregious criminal frauds ever presented
to a trial jury in federal court his
arrest meant the end of almost two
decades of illegal financial activity
number five the 20 billion fraud by
bernie madoff bernie madoff was the
organizer of the largest realized ponzi
scheme in history as former chairman of
the nasdaq stock market and his squeaky
clean image of an investment guru he
attracted several high-profile clients
such as film director steven spielberg
but his fraudulent investments were
exposed in 2008
his ponzi scheme wiped out people's
fortunes and more than 15 400 claims
were filed against him he became so
hated that he had to wear a bulletproof
vest to court
in march of 2009 madoff pled guilty to
the charges and the courts stripped him
and his wife of their wealth he was
sentenced to jail for 150 years where he
passed away in april of 2021
if you want to see the full story on
bernie madoff you can check out the cold
fusion episode on him
okay i said i'd say five but here's a
bonus one number six the entire u.s
federal reserve system
according to some economists the entire
u.s federal reserve system is a ponzi
scheme here's the oversimplified version
the united states has a huge national
debt which is owed to foreign countries
such as china and japan these countries
and other investors loan the us
government money in exchange for a
stable return these debts are short-term
debts so the u.s government has to pay
back these investors trillions yearly
currently the united states can't pay
because they don't produce and export
enough goods to support their spending
so
whenever the debt expires the government
either creates more money through the
federal reserve or borrows more money
from new investors to pay off the old
debt
in essence they're borrowing money from
new investors to pay off the old
investors just like bernie madoff
in fact in jail bernie madoff even said
the us government is running the biggest
ponzi scheme on earth and he would know
a ponzi scheme if he sees one
he's not the only one though michael
snyder wrote the fed is the biggest
ponzi scheme in the history of the world
and if the american people truly
understood how it really works they
would be screaming for it to be
abolished immediately
and michael lombard stated quote right
now we are seeing the government hoping
investors would keep reinvesting in u.s
bonds while the fed picks up the slack
but what happens if they say we want our
money back it would make madoff's ponzi
scheme look like a joke
so you can take that for what you will
[Music]
so in wrapping up what are the signs to
watch out for to avoid ponzi schemes
to avoid falling victim people should
always watch out for returns that seem
too good to be true a promise of high
returns with minimal risk is a sure red
flag such investments just don't exist
usually with high returns you should see
high risk
another red flag could be the
consistency of returns
investments are linked to market
conditions and that should affect the
returns that they bring
if a scheme promises consistent high
returns without being affected by market
conditions there's a good chance that it
could be a ponzi scheme
as technology evolves there's going to
be new forms of the same old trick
fake cryptocurrencies are the new flavor
of the decade so far and the reason
being is that they're poorly understood
by many
very recently some large youtubers had
taken part in a scam called save the
children coin
a coin which promised to help kids in
need but also was promised to go up in
value the scheme promised to go to the
moon but in reality it just crashed
those who had the knowledge that the
whole thing was a scam got out
immediately with a bunch of money and
everyone else lost everything so be
careful out there
if you're curious and want to see more
on the save the children coin the
youtube channel coffeezilla did a great
series on it
before we continue i just want to give a
quick shout out to today's sponsor
raycon wireless earbuds
raycon reached out to me to try their
wireless earbuds so i decided to give
them a go
i've been using their everyday earbuds
for a few weeks now they fit really well
in my ears and there's a bunch of
different tips to suit whatever ear
shape you have i use them when i go on
my morning run and also for coals with
their built-in microphone i didn't have
any issues with them coming loose or
falling out of my ears at all these
earbuds have eight hours of playback
time and 32 hour battery life raycon
start at half the price of other premium
audio earbuds but you're getting the
same sound if for any reason you're
unsatisfied with your purchase there's a
45 day free return policy so if you want
to support the channel and pick up
something for yourself or someone else
visit the link in the description or go
to
buyreicon.com
cold fusion and use the code holiday to
get 15 off your entire recon order
anyway as for this video i hope you did
enjoy this episode and it can help you
to identify a ponzi scheme and if not i
hope it was at least entertaining
so i know that you guys love the fraud
and scam videos on this channel so to
celebrate there's a limited release on
the merch store these are exclusive
designs that would only be around for a
short while so check it out in the
description below
okay so that's about it from me
i hope you enjoyed this episode my name
is dagogo and you've been watching cold
fusion follow me on instagram and
twitter and i'll see you again soon for
the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]